[Music]
school sports looks accomplishments
people aren't reverse-engineering their
kids for happiness their engineering
them to make them look good yeah parents
stop [ __ ] up on some real [ __ ] [ __ ]
you like you should not be using your
kids as a tool to make you look good
you got your perspective
[Applause]
[Music]
super excited about today's podcast I
have Alan Robinson superstar wide
receiver for Chicago Bears former
Jacksonville Jaguar won't you tell the
vaynernation
a little bit of just about yourself in a
hole if somebody just me knew they're
like yo what's good who are you yeah so
for me a grown up born and raised in
Detroit Michigan you know I think again
now that I'm in in Chicago you know it's
very similar you know it's a lot of
things as far as me growing up you know
I can just kind of relate to as far as
city wise things like that you know and
also even you know going to Penn State
you know I give a lot of respect to
Detroit into my parents you know I mean
cuz that kind of molded me to be you
know everything at where I'm at today
even as far as you know know how to get
through adversity you know knowing the
value of just having a work ethic you
know nothing that's something that's
that's that's very like not understood
for a lot of people you know people are
given a lot of things you know even when
it comes to me and just kind of been
able to you know I'm saying dig back
into different situations and relate
different situations in my life you know
I can kind of attest to things that when
I was younger you know things at mom
things that my dad told me you know
things that wasn't me from I love that
and that's what I'm about as you know so
like give me give me a straight up story
right off the bat of something that you
either did that was good bad or
indifferent or somebody did something
bad you different to you in pop I would
say the big thing that really sticks to
me in high school is you know for me oh
you're in high school I'm in high school
how good of an athlete are you at that
point at that point Tom I'll probably
say I'm low I'm a decent athlete you
know I'm kind of smaller is my freshman
years actually I would say going into
high school so like gone from eighth
grade to ninth grade I wanted to go to
the public school you know that wasn't
round cuz your friends around my area
because my friends were born there you
know a lot of the coaches and thing like
that knew me they had watch me play
Little League it's where they're growing
up you know but again in middle school I
wasn't the best student you know I would
get in trouble you know doing it doing
stupid stuff
I know getting suspended from school and
I'm saying like the normal like stuff so
my parents they wanted to see me picture
for me how rough we're not like in a
scale of like want you rough [ __ ] to
like ten is like Beverly here like where
does your neighborhood that you grew up
here um so I grew up like growing up I
grew up actually in Detroit and then we
actually moved to South field so I would
probably say I went from like a two to
three to like a five okay so arm
but again just kind of even in that
situation I kind of dive in that a
little bit later but you know going back
from 8th to 9th grade you know for me I
want to go to the to the public school
you know that's what everybody who was
familiar with me I was familiar with
everybody you know but my parents wanted
me to get away from that and they wanted
me to get away from that to have a
different experience you know because
they they saw right in their eyes they
saw where they thought I was headed you
know so it was that professionally from
us nah it was just because I get them
you just will you going down you had
something yeah there's yeah and they
just want me to go down the wrong road
you know getting caught up and stuff
with my friends and stuff like that so
they sent me to a prep school to
all-boys prep school at that which is
like just like I was like when they
really finally laid down they're like
you're going probably pops looking you
said you were going
did you like literally I'm trying to
think of your age group did you go out
like on AOL or like did you go outside
and be like oh [ __ ] yes exactly yes
that's exactly what you know so you went
to your three best friends said there's
some [ __ ] cuz they had like seven or
sevens and stuff right definitely yeah
cuz I mean for me I didn't I didn't know
nobody who was going out there it
probably like an hour some change away
from like where I live you know Sports
was a bunch of white kids a little bit
of both the sports had diversity but it
kind of Elysees no really right it's a
good prep school wants to be good at
sports bring in the alley is America
fresh it's right
so would you like I was like a senior
you are cute so I could see how you
could pull that off I get it go ahead so
you know so then you throw all that in
the mix so it didn't light and it's
probably like half of to my have great
year you know um half through eighth
grade year when they told you this is
locked or this is like the play like
this is like my emotions you know so I
go to like comment cause if they give it
to you hard like those kind of parents
or do they did mom like subtly subtly
even this energy you could take visits
you know I'm since I took like I missed
my own day like regular school take a
visit to the school you know I'm saying
like he was like it was the most boring
thing I've ever been a part of in my
life
this is how did not want to go here like
so so you like went through got in the
car like mom I'm not going yes that's
exactly literally exactly how was so
then you go like a little bit so near my
dad's like um you know like they had
like a seven or seven you know I'm
coming in the spring so my dad took me
up there I didn't get out the car I told
him like I wasn't going there I think
about the car mmm so long story short I
had a conversation with one of my in the
eighth grade with like one of the
teachers and he's like you know
everybody raised me I was going to lose
going to South though high school that's
like the public school then it's like
another school like that's like a
crosstown I'm saying raising me going to
school I didn't raise my hand for
neither not just was that kid so he like
so like were you going to school you
know I'm saying I was like I'm gonna I'm
gonna watch a lake and he's like no
you're not you can't like get into
Orchard Lake you know I'm saying that
kind of vibe and from that moment which
interesting it switched from that moment
forward new switch no yeah so god I [ __ ]
with that so that's why yeah like when
somebody said you couldn't it made it
interesting yeah but I never forget it
like that was like the moment and I was
okay cool like I'm with it like I'll
accept the fact that yep I was cept the
fact that my parents for me to go there
i'ma go here and that's for sure and
again that's kind of where was that for
me and then what happened did you now
I'm really into this story are you do
you love it in September when you get
there is it instant love so the first
three months and then it got good hated
the first year or I'll start liking you
and okay wait a minute I had it the
first year I'll tell you well year yep
so for me I'm playing freshman football
but mine I'm small I play running back
and cornerback at this time you know K
I'm still a pretty good player but going
to any other school besides that when I
wasn't gonna play freshman you were no
no so I'm like I'm playing to catch me
and this is frustrating and I would
either say be a varsity got it so their
school team was that good DNA we're good
I'm not gonna lie they were good that's
not a bar C but yeah I'm player you
could say here so it's like I'm like
tell them I'm waiting you you didn't
have the growth spurt yet no I probably
like five eight at the time and then
how'd it go so I named in rushman so
then fast forward to a basketball season
I'm on a freshman basketball and I tell
my dad like
like I'm like I'm nice cool like this is
ridiculous it's probably harder like
that and greatest feel crazy I'm on
freshmen freshman football freshman
basketball but what about socially
socially it was different you know I
still have like my culture of of people
who kind of came from the city as well
we all have in the same mindset like we
all compromise we don't want to be here
I see day one you're looking around you
like I gotcha yeah and like we don't
want em saying we all kind on the same
page like our parents got us out here
you know like it is what it is like like
um the schools to send a bus to the city
to pick us all up at like 6 o'clock in
the morning so they were your homies
yeah so we just all take the bus in the
morning like every morning but we hate
this
like why are our parents sent us out
here we all just want to go to our
neighborhood schools all right so then
fast-forward to the basketball
I'm not freshmen coming off the bench at
there so I'm like I'm like suit life
it's the worst so I think the first five
to six games I interrupt you just
knowing how successful you've been at
the NFL level I'm so happy right now so
much of what I do is for the 14 year old
me I had nobody to look up to there was
no entrepreneurship mmm there was no
cool entrepreneurship there wasn't even
entrepreneurship I'm just so happy right
now because I know right this second
whether it's right this second or in
four weeks when somebody sees this
there's like a 15 year old that just now
gets to use this comp yeah that's like
like I could I'm on the bench Abascal
you and I think it's over but wait a
minute what let me keep listening go
ahead
so first I think first game first six
games I have like come off the bench oh
I'll take that back first two games I
came with the bench I came out the
missionary's first game I had 28 came
off the bench in the second game I had
like 26 so now I'm crazier so now I'm
starting next game I have like 25 next
game 26 next game I 28 next game 30
halfway through the season
I'm on JV when my just our freshman on
the bench
yeah so then I get move up to JV then I
do that like I do the same thing on JV
pretty much and they're like the coach
comes to me he's I look um and like I
didn't want to start you you know to
kind of mess up like the chemistry
because like we already had our starting
point on everything we have like our
league playoffs even though his JV so I
started for the playoffs we end up
losing the first game but now things are
kind of starting to change them
but you know um because you're getting
some clout in school yeah and and just
like it's more of a it's more of a good
yeah so it's flowing and again like it
was very competitive from like a back
from a sports standpoint because you got
a lot of kids coming from all different
places to come to the school to play
sports so it's also two freshmen who
came in the same year as me who played
varsity Wow
they they end up transferring this
sophomore year really yeah
they have both of them end up
transferring sophomores did either what
I'm going to have good college er oh no
they did not
I think I think one of them um he in a
plane at college but um I don't think I
got any big skies but so then I saw my
boy Sean moody and CJ cuz they they were
they before my guys but um they both end
up transferring their sophomore year and
then that's kind of when now it opened
up for you but everything started just
kind of change you know I'm saying cuz I
kind of was the guy who was like the the
grinder you know I'm saying they came in
they played varsity you know I'm saying
so like they had the hype yeah but
everything just kinda started to change
and then go on to my sophomore year I'm
like 61 and a half now mm-hmm so I go
from 5-8 to 61 you know so on
that's like they're inches everything
started to change and I end up playing
Bart I'd end up playing varsity I
started off the year on JV my sophomore
year I actually didn't play football
cause I was hurt from grossberg's right
I couldn't like I couldn't I couldn't do
nothing like my body was just like sore
like for real so I didn't play football
my sophomore year hold on Allen Robinson
who you are right this second did not
play somewhere you know on some my body
hurts yeah I could I couldn't run I
couldn't run I couldn't write because
you changed right that's why you're not
a running back spot exactly so like my
whole body I go to Mike's I go for my
five seven five eight nine six one and a
half six two so my whole body has like
changed and like I'm progressively
getting better but like over the summer
like I couldn't do summer workouts and
stuff so by the time November December
hit I'm feeling good I'm ready to play
basketball so then I play basketball I
start off on JV those dudes kind of
transfer throughout the course of the
year it's a lot of stuff I didn't
missing games like it's a lot going on
my school was like the literally like
the NBA when it comes to like dudes who
like I don't
to be here and I'm saying again you got
dudes like not coming to practice just
because I don't feel like a transfer guy
process they're looking at other schools
and stuff so long searched ain't a
transfer I get moved up to varsity into
my sophomore year and then I didn't the
following year now I'm on varsity I'm
six-three everything's like lock yeah
junior football what happens uh I have a
good year um I play my receiver I play
receiver I play receiver in corner so
you recorder running back prior to that
could you always catch well I can always
catch and I remember having a
competition with my dad after hitting a
gross sport they like you know that I
didn't play myself a mirror so much so
then like that whole like all like the
whole spring after basketball they are
like we bout to like you're about to
receiver don't you hand my putting ring
back my whole life I don't know how it
really is to play receiver you know so I
mean just from playing running a time
how you just see the feel and and
movements and stuff is different even
when you catch the ball on how you like
press block so one of things that's
crazy
seriously I quadrupled down once you
sign with us like watching you like do
you like I'm about to give you a huge
compliment you know in comparison to all
the jet receivers I've watched and like
through the years like your separation
sometimes feels uncomfortable like do
you think that's running back chef for
sure cuz you're really just guys being
able to do it and even like when you see
the when you catch the ball and like
seeing different like angles and things
like that is all in my I would have
tested being a running back you know cuz
I I got play running back I mean I play
yeah I play running back my whole life
up until my junior year in high school
so then I play running I play receiver
my junior year senior year freshman year
college sophomore year junior in college
before I got any photos so only time I
play receiver was like those five years
when did it click receiver I'll probably
say going into my senior year during
that spring and summer during that
spring you clip I would say basketball
basketball to both um I just don't think
as a freshman that you were gonna be or
a sophomore you're gonna be a basketball
for sure me me and mock one of my high
school coaches have a base always tell
me your first offer is gonna come from
from like your first big offers gonna
come from football before basketball and
then we always go back and forth with it
like going into my senior year like I
said my junior I'm like literally taking
the net he like texts me a number he'll
call this number so I called a number
they answered the phone is it's a
Minnesota coaching staff and they and
that was my first offer actually my
first offer was a big ten offer that's
so um after that you know everything
just changed it got real because my
parents in and shout out to my parents
cuz throughout the whole process of I
like my mom still at my house right now
I was like a whole thick book of like
everybody that like sent me letters the
places the schools that I want to go to
us in and out questionnaires us making
like highlight tapes and things like
that centered to different schools and
stuff so my parents definitely were
heavily involved for your parents
athletes they were not they were not I
just think that for my parents you know
from five years old I probably been one
of the most competitive probably even
before that probably one of the most
competitive kids in sports that like you
probably could did you cry when he lost
of course like I cried basically until I
was like 12 if I lost in anything I was
also so confident I was delusional I
mean I I cried cuz I was stunned I
didn't win same-same in there I remember
it used to be so easy to be so bad in my
dad's I looked like you win a lot of
games he stopped crying yeah like you
went a lot of games I know so and I
always tell people you know having you
know I'm saying having kids and like
having I don't know how I would want to
introduce like sports tomorrow like kids
well there's a huge different variable
when I was doing a wine show on the
internet back in the day I had Wayne
Gretzky on because he had a wine which
is super cool greatest hockey player of
all time and we're and super funny story
there is people before we got on set
we're like yo Wayne's very introverted
he's not going to say what's up he
doesn't it's not bad just don't worry
about I'm like cool of course I'm thing
I'm the most charismatic [ __ ] on earth
we're gonna be best friends in two
minutes sure enough like just one little
opening and I didn't know this I didn't
know this because I don't do homework I
mentioned that I was from Belarus he's
like my grandfather's from Belarus which
is cool cuz I didn't know and like the
greatest hockey player having Russian
descent makes sense we got into a
conversation because it was something
wrong with the camera actually and
somehow we got into him saying that he
wouldn't let his kids play hockey and I
thought it was super fresh and and and
that's with your story right like it's
same with me as an entrepreneur like I
think every day about my daughter and
son I'm like you know I'm not gonna
pressure them to be an entrepreneur and
I'm not even sure I want them to be
because you know what happens it's gonna
be comparison City now in baseball we
have a whole wave right now of kids who
are coming up who are the juniors yeah
glad yes
you know Biggio Bichette I mean it's
crazy and baseball right now we see them
football right you know like the BOCES
yeah right you know you see it but like
it's an interesting conversation of like
do you want your child you to do it when
they have to look up to something here
you're gonna have some real all-time
success for sure I mean for me honestly
I wouldn't know I'm kind of selfish that
since I I took it one at a time you know
I'm saying like like when I was young
like when I have a son I wanted a
quarterback I tell everybody you know
but that's kind of the selfish me but
you know I think in general of sports
like I would love for him to own the
place for nothing sports mode me in a
lot of different ways you know I'm
saying it taught me how to go through
adversity you taught me you know the
value of a of a work ethic it taught me
the value of perfecting a craft in a
sense of just learning a craft and one
to perfect on craft for everybody by the
way if you listen we're about to get to
calls putting your phone number on
Facebook especially if you're a Bears
Penn State and Jags fan I want to give
you that at-bat or as you're listening
adversity mindset high school life I
don't how much and I think this confuses
people how much film work have you done
in your career how much feel a lot like
tell tell the averages out there like I
think they just don't realize how much
studying you [ __ ] do yeah a lot
that's the thing I mean most of our days
is watching film you know I mean if you
look at even like now you know just like
when we come into the facility like
we're in a facility 10 to 11 hours a day
I'll probably say do you like film work
or do you I do I like you like it yeah I
like and are you like straight up
looking for like oh this dude under
Lyons he has a tick like she's looking
for the son
watch when you watching defenses you
know watching tendencies watching
players witnesses also for me I'm big on
I like watching other receivers you know
right now even in my iPad you know um
over this next month before I get back
to oth I'm up for sure you know watch
all of Mara Cooper's targets watch all
that kena Allen's targets you know just
guys who are was coming out of Cal I
wanted the Jets to take him in the first
round all my friends were making fun of
me he slipped a third round I believe
you because it'd be sonic career is a
beast and and if I was the Jets owner
yeah so just watching guys like that
like Michael Thomas Julio Jones you know
cuz you see these dudes who are you know
I'm saying
very good receivers on that note pretty
game work out postgame daps are you the
guy that talks to guys before the game
are you guy that talks to people after
game or you talk to nobody never ever
outta game after game for sure before
game it just depends they just it
depends on if you went to college with
them under your boy it's tough to say
would you go up to hoot like you played
the Falcons next year will you go up to
Julio if you're both running there early
even before to say you're early here
we've like yo good year or so well yeah
definitely cuz again I may use because
you're competitive for sure so I'm like
I see this to think of my football
personally personally I'm competitive of
me personally I'm not going up against
Julio I agree you know I'm saying so
just like [ __ ] the Falcons yeah yeah
yeah no I agree with that but you know
now cornerback wise corner not non
enough cuz I'm real cool diría slay and
we play against each other you kill all
the time today I know you're about to
get paid so good for you but bro Allen
got you last year that one play still
but that's the play was referencing on
separation bro
so like slay I won't talk to him before
the game you know I'm saying but after
guys the game all oh yeah I'm saying
that's my boy like like um you know I'm
saying we came out a year apart you know
we started off in the same agency and
I'm saying so just over time I got about
what about when you who's in the league
that you went to school with Adrian Amos
oh I love that did not talk to him
before the game and that's my that's my
that's my boy you know yeah for sure
what about the week ahead like when
you're playing slay like will you text
them on Wednesday like boy
got you none okay yeah I'll get on
that's right now let's cut up into there
I'm really like when it comes to source
of [ __ ] when it comes to like during
this season I'm really like probably the
most quiet and like innocent person good
I know that I don't do like role I don't
even hit you up during the season I
don't do anything I don't literally you
know I don't even talk to you I know
you're in your cocoon yeah that's what
that's really what it is
well that's really what it is just being
in a literally in a cocoon cuz that's
the thing you have your seven the seven
pretty much I get it you got numbers
let's get one in real quick this is fun
Allen I get that cocoon [ __ ] man my big
thing is I used to think that I wouldn't
DAP after the game because I was such a
source port and you just like spit in my
hand for like that little even like cry
and leave as I've gotten older I'm like
oh no no no I'm competitive on the field
but after he I'm like how's your mother
you know like I'm a human so and I've
seen that myself in business like I'm
I'm a human to my competitors and I
sustaining you respect your competitors
that's I respect I was thinking anybody
going for it for real Jared hello Jared
its Gary Vaynerchuk and Alan Robinson it
was good yeah no way Oh a hundred fifty
thousand of these and it's never worked
but we do it this morning no god this
[ __ ] God sent from God or intuition or
whatever it is the Gary Vee magic your
magical moon so you never know it this
thank you brother
where you from and what's your question
so I'm from Colorado Las Vegas I'm 21
years old I spent about keening 12 years
in a vault
mostly from Colorado and the Grand
Junction Aspen area and I'm a musician
and I played football for nine years and
you know this is probably the only
opportunity I'm gonna get on this but
one day I'm also gonna say an Allen I'm
gonna meet you too now that we've you
know had this phone conversation
question is I'm gonna need to PV and I'm
gonna change the music industry in the
world for the better
let me give you let me let me give you a
sneak peak I think the judge I think the
Jets play the Bears in two years
so like when that schedule comes out
you should definitely take a look I now
that we might be going to a 17 game
schedule my ability to know who the Jets
play nine years out is changing a little
bit but but that's gonna be your hat bro
you can meet me and Alan on the same day
okay how much games I gotta go to I'm
gonna meet you guys and I'm moving
actually to LA and the next month
actually April 2nd is when I've got
wanted to move out there good for you
and I'm going to be doing stand-up
comedy and music and I'm gonna be trying
to become the biggest thing in the whole
entire world so hopefully I can get on
to y'all's level and then we can me and
be buddies and bro we can we can we can
we can mean be buddies before you get to
that level do whatever it takes I don't
care Gary I you changed my life with
motivation our solution two hours of you
you know I'm gonna be at your funeral
whatever it takes to make you think I'm
watching you on the field
thank you so much brother do you have a
quick one do you have a quick question
or you just fired up because I like
fired up oh I'm for one fired up that
I'm talking about here oh right now Gary
beef but the question is where do you
guys see the league going for one like I
feel like I said the league went through
you know weird political energies in
mainstream games is the way we're social
medias evolved it's it's over the next
five to ten where do you see it going
this mean I'm a huge lover of the game
where do we see it go great question
we're gonna drop you up in a second but
like as a huge celebrity game are you a
Broncos fan and it's hard being a
blocker spin right now you know I'm from
I got a lot of family for Malinois and
I'm I was born there I'm from like I
live it's always one two three so you're
busy I mean yeah I'm actually this is
very important to me
you need to save up some money and buy
an Allen Bears Jersey I promise you yes
I believe I will I will send you a DM
and Facebook you the allenbys Jersey do
me a favor do me a favor because I want
to see it and the number one place is
good for everybody to know the number
one place that is most guaranteed for me
to see it is Twitter like if you use a
carry be like I just see a lot in that
uh and though two one two nine three one
five seven three one my text platform I
see a lot DM I'm just getting 10,000 a
day it just it's impossible right Allen
thank you brother
have a great day I'm glad you got
through and where do you think the
leaves going next 5-10 years I set up
this podcast with your thoughtfulness
what's uh what's the interesting hot
take or a random thought that you have
that maybe others don't see yeah
anything crazy cuz I think can I give
you a crazy in a fairly no I'm just
weird thought that in 20 or 30 years the
NFL might play without helmets I could
see that I can see like the soft helmets
like they do a 707 you know it's
interesting I've been thinking a lot
about like helmets are a problem because
people don't know their faces right like
NBA players we hear a lot of I talk to a
lot of football players like [ __ ]
helmets
nobody you know you know this you're in
the AR but this is real like a lot of
football players wear big-ass chains
with numbers on it cuz they know
subconsciously me nobody knows who they
are and [ __ ] superstar like that at
that level you watch I would outnumber
[ __ ] five you know and so there's that
I think that the completions and like
like what would happen if big dudes like
that like rugby everyone's like Gary
they're too big and fast like you watch
rugby those rub me [ __ ] you they get
after they get after it in New Zealand
in South Africa and those places and
because they know they don't have
helmets they don't have as much [ __ ] go
down you have that helmet you [ __ ]
just go in in like a missile I think my
weird heartache is 25 years real NFL no
helmet I see that I could see that and I
also think that the whole I think the
fantasy football has helped out the
whole like facial thing yeah I think
that army people play I do not play
famous did you ever consider it have you
ever no I never have weird yeah I I
actually kind of want to play basketball
but I don't know just the whole like has
anybody in the league ever come up to me
like you'll have a good game today I do
my fantasy something with you yeah it's
crazy yeah that's crazy I love that [ __ ]
but I think that I've helped out a lot
you know the horse cart thing that I've
been telling you about
I've been thinking about him like man in
24 months cuz basketball carts are going
through the roof I like some of these
guys are gonna like make jokes and be
like yo drop 30 tonight it
about 100 euro Keys last night no not
with the gambling and things like that
you know everybody like the whole like
fantasy thing is going crazy I probably
say fans are yelling at you 80% of yo
drivers who I encounter pretty nada yeah
bring fantasy oh yeah you're on the road
you think it's a hostile environment in
Minnesota and Minnesota fans like Alan
have a good game I got you in fantasy
that's the exact [ __ ] joke that's
where I get [ __ ] pissed I get crazy
on that [ __ ] as a real fan like when my
crew like of jet bands like quietly
close I'll never forget this my brother
Alex Klein [ __ ] clapped for AJ Green
on a play against the Jets the Jets
bangles game I lost my mind
I'm like we're [ __ ] jet fans [ __ ]
your fantasy team matches ass I don't
give a [ __ ] if you know we have a sauna
second nervous everybody like you got a
row everyone's soft [ __ ] all of you
people let's put another number and I'm
getting pissed like if you're a [ __ ]
Vikings fan you can't like Alan it's a
rule you know somebody yeah it's some
Vikings fan that's jucier I got you on
fantasy have a big game but I hope you
lose that just probably the best from I
just like the best family as a player in
a school environment the Green Bay
cannon you know it's Gary Vaynerchuk and
Alan Robinson it's happening bro where
you from I'm in Knoxville Tennessee from
Nashville I get it I know Knoxville okay
of course make you have your own place
if I or is it liner marketing that's in
Chattanooga that's exactly right so I
know Tennessee quite well for that
reason we got a [ __ ] yep thank you bro
what's up what's your what's your
question I just heard I was talking
about how like um was also really
passionate about basketball in high
school playing bowls and seeing like a
future in basketball and I was just
curious I know a lot of athletes are
better at once before people push them
towards one sport more but they may like
the other sport better I had a friend
like that in high school who went to go
play in Miami just because he could play
football and
skeeball the same time that was like
really important to him instead so I was
just curious about that something that's
not really talked about with athletes
and kind of the same thing for
entrepreneurs yes lean in what
everybody's cooking towards their work
may be better at or do you think the
money is yeah yeah it's a great question
how did you how did you personally think
about that you loved basketball to this
day I love basketball I know it like
last night honest I'll watch a I'll
watch a basketball game over a football
game week for sure
um when he gets around playoff time is
kind of different you know I'm saying is
I'm like I'm like actually immersed in
the in the NFL and like after playing in
the playoffs things like that yeah so
but for me you basketball I probably say
was pushed more about what time did you
a hundred you might be not when you went
when Penn so what happened what was your
most serious basketball offer um my high
school coach told me I couldn't went to
Michigan State and play both action was
a guy named Dion same shouted Dion who I
played in Chicago with his well he went
to my high school he went to Michigan
State he played both you know so on what
made you go to Penn State I want the I
want to play football
um I want to monitor my senior year you
had going to my senior I had decided I
said I was one play football in college
about the answer is a good moment why
football was just it was easier not
easier in the sense that's like easy to
do but for me on the field you were
better in way better at it and let's
talk about it does that mean you chose a
path that gave you confidence could lead
to financial for sure for sure for what
probably was some I mean it's pretty
obvious especially in this last 48 hours
I've been with you like basketball was a
bigger love for sure um but I just think
that as I started to even my senior year
when I started to really dive in cuz I
mean I had had a really good senior in
basketball but once I start to dive in
to football and I really like put my
mind there and like once my senior year
for me I was all I was all in it you
know so like I still have like a weird
like love for you know but just I don't
know it was just different when it came
to like football you know I'm sounds
like when I would step on the field just
my crap
and how I would perfect this yeah was a
lot different it was a lot different
interesting in this even it's so
different that is that it's hard to
explain because even I took a lot of
time I never I don't know last month
actually picked up a basketball I played
like five on five or something this is
my passion and my love for the game is
so high so intense you know I wouldn't
even want to put myself there mentioning
like your light let's go to the reckon
by five on five cuz I may not leave I I
get that it's almost like how I think
about meditation yeah I don't want to
meditate cuz I'm so happy with my mental
state like I almost weirdly understand
what you just saw it's like a normal
person kind of here is that like you
don't even want to play a random
basketball game cuz you know you might
get in it exactly you know when people
talk about Jordan and he joke about
Jordan he said I like Michael Jordan had
these car games and I he wouldnt let the
person leave like they'll be their flesh
that's how I feel about basketball so as
I have a great is a great cheers Jets
beer story I told her the other day if
you guys heard it my best friend Brandon
was a Cubs fan baseball and weed
baseball cards together and he came over
one night to sleep over the night before
a baseball card show and we played
Madden and he took the Bears he didn't
give a [ __ ] about the Bears when he was
Chicago cuz he was Cubs and some
miraculous way he beat me after I like
destroyed him every other time and I
wouldn't let him go to sleep it was like
midnight and I wouldn't let him go to
sleep until we rematched
and then I could tell he was [ __ ]
and because he was mad that I was
forcing him to play so he was like not
trying but then I countered it with like
make him pretend he was trying and blew
him out like 72 to nothing and was like
in his face I like to him
exactly and that's kind of how and it's
crazy because the last kind of serious
that I played was a intramural well not
intramural but basketball class at Penn
State we had a basketball class okay and
I play like my sophomore and that's why
use to be so intense I remember playing
in the game scoring like 60 70 points
and everyone's like yo chill you know
they used to call me a gym class hero
cuz in gym class in high school I would
go hard like sawa I got all these in f's
on some real [ __ ] in freshman sophomore
junior these are literally my grades
this is my report card but if you notice
only four A's in high school histories
freshman sophomore
and senior year Jim was the aunt what
health - huh you do your health bro you
don't understand how much I check the
[ __ ] out I would go into class and read
the baseball card guide and the Wine
Spectator sell and sling candy and cards
and just make money you guys ready for
that early on in school slinging candy I
love it can't thank you so much brother
thank you so much I mean I'm gonna have
friends that can't believe I talked to
Gary Vee and I'm gonna have a friends
who can't believe I talked to Alan
Robert have a dream moment thank you
take care bro let's get one more in now
anything before we get further along and
wrap up anything you want to talk about
anything on your mind anything your
passion about anything cool good
question uh you know I for me I'm I'm
passion about a lot actually
I've kind of hope it's been like a work
in progress but I actually have like
some sample and stuff I had a wave where
I was like making swim trunks yeah so
like um cuz this is the thing so me my
buddies we would like hang out or
something but if you ever got like a
pool party or something like that like
you got our swim trunks especially if
it's like in Vegas or something of
course I was like no you got to like the
normal I store to get swim trunks all of
them have like Sun sex like flamingos
and [ __ ] like everything that nobody
wants to wear it is you know so it's
like so I'm like damn I guess no
fashionable swim trunks so I was like
you know what I'm gonna just start
making some so even I order some trucks
they even like my buddies and stuff
where our autumn ones that I made get
out I'm dead serious
is there a way to see them oh I don't I
just have samples right now so you know
start the process I mean because that's
a thing we've been in the clothing
clothing is unreasonably expensive
universe and for some reason so just out
the over the years you know me I've just
been kind of you know I'm saying like
like making sample was making designs
you know I'm saying so it's like my [ __ ]
look like it's fashion I got like any
like camo like different kind of camos
plants checker boards yeah you know I'm
saying anything that you will kind of
say that's like yeah they're just more
fashionable something that you can
actually like you probably just whereas
shorts you know I'm saying but they swim
trunks I've always thought that like
like I hate the concept of like going to
somewhere where I know
have to go into swim trunks where I
would only wear swim trunks all day cuz
I'm too lazy to switch em hmm and was
like they need to do something with this
and that's the thing and that's and
that's kind of what I was making like I
said before you would like the swim
trunks that I make or you know I'm
saying in that I'll make in the future
our swim trunks that you're not just
wearing them just because I got it we'll
get some swim trunks so let me go to
Dick's Sporting Goods so someone get
like these like swim trunks a sunset
surf I'm saying this person's surfing
all my swim trunks I get some camo or
some that likes that's funny Wayne hello
oh man girl is going home man life's
good man say what's up Talan yo was good
look that I actually got both I'm
actually your husband Alabama so I'm
about an hour outside of Chattanooga
that's uh um and I'm I'm actually
familiar with the soccer grew up to up
and chat with Mickey so I just want to
say preset you for having me on
so happy to have you bro what's good
never thought I really know I'm a former
linebacker former player and I really
wanted to ask a question to Allen like I
have a young daughter looking to have
you know some then one day the how do
you introduce like manhood the kind of
what it means to be a man to your kids
without emphasizing men and emphasizing
what it means to like make money just
names you talk about Gary like empathy
no kindness understanding no things like
how to be actually as a professional
athlete where a lot of things are
throwing a fit here now how do you have
a person ahead in how you be a good read
that's a great bro thank you so much for
asking that question go ahead Ali
honestly I would just say it comes down
to just like the moral compass of
everything you know I think if you kind
of set the morals of everything I think
that's what people live by you know cuz
again growing up I mean my dad and my
family you know we didn't have a ton of
money or anything like that but you know
everything
my dad just instilled in me internal
ultimately translated to me to be able
to have success you know again we didn't
talk about you know like yeah it will be
cool for you to get to NFL and be rich
you know just like you know I'm saying
this is what this will hard work because
you just would dedication get you this
with being able to fight through
adversity yeah you know and it's able
for you to to to balance your life and
you know to push through a lot of
different things you know that's the
thing I mean people go through a lot of
different situations you know I'm saying
but at the end of the day if you you
know if you know your goal and you know
what it take to get to your goal and you
have the morals to be able to get there
and you made to get there you know and
everything else to kind of figure itself
out well what's really crazy about your
question bro is that the fact that
you're even asking it and using words
like kindness and empathy like like you
don't even know the emotion that's
running through my body right now bro
how old are you I'm thirty live here man
you don't even know like like obviously
because you know the Sasha group which
is the office we have in Chattanooga
like like and Micky and you're calling
so obviously you know a lot about me I
know it I know everything about you Gary
like no cat like I'm on my social medias
the track therapist but like everything
that I do is about transparency and
about understanding how to actually get
to the bottom line without sacrificing
yourself so that was really my base but
I play I played football in college I
thought I was going to the NFL
[ __ ] happen so I had to say how do I get
to the end goal without you know and
even my hat yeah even though I tell
people all the time you know like even
from even from what you're saying right
now listen to you talk you may not
ultimately got to the NFL but where you
got to mentally you know it's a lot
further than anybody else would have
been able to get to and I don't know
what football did that for you or
anything or what did that for you
busting out all the time but let me say
this
it's true though you're you've already
won because your perspective for the
question is a winning question exactly
you already know the answer that you
asked because you know that I and others
and now more of us are starting to
educate the culture that [ __ ] money
examine and of course when people who
couldn't be an Allen they're like easy
for you to say but they don't know
we were pre-money I agree they don't
know how happy we were in our process
and it's a lot of paper to have any slob
people who have money that you see go
through a lot of crazy [ __ ] you know I'm
saying but in the day you see a lot
people who don't have that much money
who are the happiest people you know so
I mean you can't even really correlate
you know the the manhood the the
kindness and all that to money you know
it's just it's all morals in itself you
know and then whatever comes from that
is gonna be success and bro what's real
interesting is you have a daughter right
and you said I'm gonna have a son and
that's and you know I understand guy
culture I also first had a daughter you
know like what's really I love I'm
actually I'm a proud girl I have a few
more girls right sure you seen it they
say that terrifies me is knowing that my
father is gonna watch what I do you know
there your daughter will listen to you
mine
my daughter is the most emotionally
intelligent five-year-old world but my
son let me give you a little bit of
knowledge right here your daughter's
gonna watch everything you're doing -
you want to get really terrified get
really terrified the way you interact
with your daughter is going to be the
fundamental framework of how she chooses
the person she wants to be with for the
rest of her life whether that's in the
sari or running away from somebody like
their dad so they're all watching let's
start there they're all watching number
two number two you this is over you
already won Allen nailed there which I
was just watching Allen like I was like
Oh Allen nice have his own show
Allen picked up on exactly the game
because Allen is the byproduct of great
parenting and so am i and the fact that
you care once you turn that fear which
I'm not even sure is fear I would argue
that you use the word terrified and you
a may be terrified or be you're just
being thoughtful yeah you know and I
appreciate and I say that as well you
know because I mean even even for me
when I think about having a son you know
it's not terrifying in a sense but you
know when you have a girl you know you
can just be a loving dad you know but at
any rate having a boy
you know I'm saying especially being
especially I mean I don't know about you
but especially being african-american
it's a lot of things that you it's a lot
of things that you have to like it's a
lot of pressure that you put on your son
before you even have a son because you
wanna know how to how to mold them to a
lot of different things you know so it's
and I and I definitely understand
because I can I can for sure attest to
it when I think about having a son it's
like damn I I want to be a loving dad
but I don't want to have too much tough
love I don't want to have too much it's
too much of that like I want to be an
empathetic dad but I also want to
prepare him for the real world here's
here's real life dad of a seven year old
you you two are gonna have lots of plans
and lots of theories and then it's gonna
be Mike Tyson [ __ ] it's really nice that
you boys have plans and then you're
gonna have one and then their
personality and their DNA is gonna
emerge lots of thoughts about my little
guy and a lot of things are like I
thought and a lot of things are not like
I thought and now it's round five and
I've been punched in the face a whole
bunch and do I have the ability to
adjust and my Buster Douglas or my Tony
Tucker right and so like you got to
figure that out for sure you got it by
the way Tony Tucker reference is a real
nerdy 1980s boxing reference which is
Tony Tucker was the boxer that made me
think Mike Tyson was vulnerable because
he fought him all white well and then
next fight he lost a Buster Douglas so
for all you boxing against that was for
you okay then I first had to get a
banana tree look yeah I appreciate you
this is what gets me fired up about life
like that phone call just inspired to
[ __ ] enemy yeah me too I feel it I feel
it like I thought you said it all the
time not even as far as you know like
it's a lot of expectations again that
you may put on a son or whatever because
it's like I mean like you have those
expectations and it comes from us
selfish selfish sense a little bit you
know but it's like you only want the
best by the end of the day you got to
just take a step back and say it comes
from a selfish place for sure and the
only way to be a great parent is to be
selfless and you know this you grew up
in sports
all those delusional parents that are
ragging their kids in the ground who
have no shot remember being in the
league
these parents are delusional yeah and
it's selfish they want to feel good at
the Country Club and you say their boys
drop 39 it's [ __ ] up
our group school sports
looks accomplishments people aren't
reverse-engineering their kids for
happiness their engineering them to make
them look good yeah
parents stop [ __ ] up especially you
on some real [ __ ] [ __ ] you like you
should not be using your kids as a tool
to make you look good and that happens
in african-american culture yeah in
Russian immigrant culture in Asian
immigrant culture in Indian immigrant
culture like every subset ik's eminent
American white there's plenty of that
too we need to stop all right children
are not trophies representing us our
children human beings that we are
supposed to be molding and that requires
us to listen while molding with good
decision-making not listen when you know
eighth grade islands like I ain't going
no no you're molding there yeah but
that's cuz they saw the passion of sport
and ambition and competition say we're
molding yeah it's if they didn't but
they thought that you'd be six reading
catch everything but you wanted to dance
and they made you play football that's
[ __ ] up you see a kid who's not good
at school Indian immigrant parent he
doesn't or she doesn't need to be a
[ __ ] doctor engineer relax yeah there
are ways to win I know why you want them
to be an engineer or doctor Asian Indian
Russian parent it's cuz it looks good to
your parent or to your sister but it's
[ __ ] up your kid who's gonna resent
you for life stop it I agree
I know you do I've been listening my
group so does every other person that
had the miracle and let's call what it
is the luck of being the byproduct of
good parents that's who you and I are
[ __ ] matters give me good parents and a
rough situation like you and I had and
I'll show you superstars yeah for sure
the end let's all set up Alan thank you
so much no problem and thanks for having
me one what can people find you oh you
can find me on Instagram Alan Robinson
twelve or you could find me on Twitter
say mal Robinson twelve talk to me about
twelve eight was college eight was
college fifteen was Jacksonville twelve
was Chicago for me I'm a person whereas
no I liked it I'm saying when I take on
new stuff you know I'm saying like new
numbers yeah I want
I want to hold New Jersey school my
sophomore year it was uh no my junior
was 32 in my senior year was one both
basketball and football and football my
junior was 14 and then college I was
eight throughout and then Jackson I was
fifteen throughout so I got to Chicago
12 yeah thank you
[Music]